hi ET and welcome to the set of Die
Another Day
everything about bond is big
I know what it did you're a big boy
figured you could handle yourself my
character's kind of feisty
um she likes to be sexy she has some
really fabulous clothes that's for sure
well you didn't see the back
that's the best part
listen that dress is sexy but nothing
beats the iconic orange bikini Hallie
recreated the look in 2020 she was 53
and fire the thing she remembers most
about the scene quote freezing my butt
off Hallie is one of a woman beautiful
woman a little behind the scenes secret
this bedroom scene almost turned into a
disaster it was on top
uh and uh that I was on top and then she
was on top and I made her laugh
and the feet went down the wrong way I
said are you all right and
so to quote her I got behind her and I
did something
I just smacked on the back even though
you got a closed set you've still got
five people there in the room there's a
certain embarrassment Factor but you're
working with someone like Howie or
Rosalind
and it's a walk in the park this is
crazy yeah that was my first love scene
on camera so it's a pretty good way to
start right Rosamund Pike had the
pleasure of sharing the screen with not
one but two legends I see you handle
your weapon well I think Madonna was
adamant that she wasn't going to be the
only girl in a Bond movie who didn't do
bonds unfortunately for Madonna her
Cameo didn't lead to a fling with 007
But Die Another Day went on to gross
more than any other James Bond movie at
the time over 430 million dollars 20
years later it's remembered as one of
the campier Bond films come on kite
surfing in a tsunami and it also
signaled the fourth and final time
Brosnan would play Bond James Bond is
there a better role in Hollywood uh I
don't think so Bunn gets to do it all
and that's why we love him
foreign